[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
um so people in the comments and also on
the IG for JK have been asking us we did
a couple like uh am I the [__] like
threads off of Reddit and they're like
do more of those do more of those
because they like the opinions weighing
in and everything for these things so um
here's a good one that's uh very new
I am I the [__] this one's about a
gender reveal already they're the
[__] already I'm just kidding because
you shouldn't you shouldn't assume the
gender of the baby am I right yeah
spoken like a true pasadenian I'm right
okay so put yourself put yourself in the
position of this person okay so
there's these two girls all right one of
them's pregnant she brings her friend
with her to the ultrasound
and uh they do the ultrasound the
results of the gender the baby get
handed to the friend yep here you go
only you know uh and then figure out
later how you want to reveal it this
this information is being trusted to you
so the friend has it walks away with it
keeps it it's a secret the pregnant
friend is constantly hounding the friend
to just tell her she's like just tell me
everything what a stupid ass [__] so
she'll text her like all the time and be
like hey I want to know I want to know
and then we'll always follow up with
another email or a call or text and say
actually don't tell me don't tell me
don't spoil it uh exactly as stupid was
that the goal is like we're gonna go
together and then the unpregnant friend
is gonna be the the [__] Secret
Keeper the husband doesn't know the wife
doesn't know
yeah and then they're gonna have a party
and they're gonna find out yeah they're
gonna make plans for like that's why
sometimes you know when you got a friend
you got to know your friend and if I had
a friend I was like this they would come
with me I gotta go figure out I'm like
knowing who you are uh pick someone else
because I know I'm gonna get hounded and
then [__] you know flip-flop on me
and then I'm like because already this
person's already indecisive and
everything else they do all the time so
it's like weeks and weeks of constantly
hey tell me no don't tell me hey tell me
don't tell me [__] checking her ass
so hard let me just give her the
envelope I'm just like yo here's your
envelope you you choose so we're no
longer friends so that's annoying yeah
it is annoying so then it comes to
happen that like one time this friend is
at her job where she is really busy and
it's a really bad day she's super
stressed out the pregnant friend calls
her in the middle of that like heated
moment of stress and she sees her phone
and she's that it's her again you
[__] knocks it up and just goes it's
a [__] boy and then just like hangs
up yeah good good she deserves it and
then now their circle of friends is
pissed at her for being an [__] and
you should have kept it secret she
doesn't either she can find new friends
look she doesn't know the contacts who
is who's telling the story the girl that
got victimized or the the friend or the
pregnant lady the friend
of course and she's omitting so many
details I bet of course and maybe she
didn't Hound her that much I just said
you know what I'm saying yeah we need to
see the text receipts or or any proof
otherwise let's say that it is accurate
what she is saying okay fine if it's
accurate she's not that we'll do version
two next and pregnant ladies are local
yeah her friends are saying that she
should have despite the hounding that
it's you're entrusted with this thing
and you're expected to endure the house
yeah shut the [__] what the [__] well
actually to be fair though it's like if
that's the friend the pregnant lady if
that's the type of friend that you have
and your friends to the point where
you're that close it's like you already
knew that's your friend you know what I
mean that's what I'm saying but also I'd
be like you get Rebecca I can't handle
it yeah but then a lot of people are
like that though dude most people are
pushovers and most people just go uh
yeah I'll deal with it not knowing that
they just signed up for their [__]
death and then they they go through it
because they're a good friend but like
most people are [__] like this but
dude okay so I have I'm kind of split
here right so part of me is going no
she's not the [__] because that's
what the friend wanted we all have human
emotions we're all human we're all like
susceptible to this right because she
was having a bad day stressful she's
[__] tired of it I think that's fine
um on the other hand though if she feels
like she's getting hounded a lot by the
friend she should have just been like yo
honestly if you want me to tell you I'll
tell you if not you gotta stop or find
someone else because it's getting too
nuts but I think that's really mature
for a lot of people to do so yeah yeah I
mean she didn't even attempt to set a
boundary apparently in here she didn't
even say
yeah well she so she would she didn't
have a problem keeping the secret it's
just that it caught her on such a high
stress moment at work too but then
catching yourself at work is not like
it's a boy all right versus just like I
can't
exactly you know what I mean why did she
decide to pick up yeah she made a choice
she made a choice to take it out on like
maybe she's not an [__] but maybe
that was an [__] moment what if it
was on a landline though she'd even know
who it was
she saw who it was like Domino's Pizza
this [__] again yeah it's a boy it
didn't even mess it yeah
a landline she might have been on a
rotary phone maybe she was ignoring the
phone call so then she wasn't picking up
so she called her at the [__]
9-1-1 what's your emergency
what the [__] Esther God damn it it's a
boy she's a she's a dispatcher yeah
I gotta talk to you quick
but also though too the the pregnant
lady she's the one signing up for the
gender reveal right she's the one that's
like hey I don't want to know from the
top right so yeah I don't know the fact
that she's hounding her she's already
breaking but she's expecting her friend
to be complicit in this kind of like
Temptation that goes up and down the
more like Jill's right the more mature
thing to do is to be like hey you want
me to tell you or not you want to know
the more and more mature thing to do you
just don't have friends like that that's
true I'm saying that's top level
this is the [__] [__] that [__]
go oh I know what I'll do I'll have a
time capsule she buries in the backyard
digs it back up the next day
[Laughter]
is curious about her own time capsule
because she's like I don't know someone
in the future might be leaving me a
message dude time capsules are pretty
fast to add to it yeah
I don't know okay okay I know I'm
[__] around a lot but I think I think
the chick who [__] answered the phone
and did the thing they're both goddamn
annoying but I think the chick who said
the reveal is kind of an [__] oh
because she just she should have stuck
to the oath no matter what uh or shut a
boundary
[__] annoying or ignore the call you
know but but same thing though I think I
really do think they're just both idiots
absolutely it's like you know but you
have to pick
us up that's the question are we the
idiots like if any other situation is
like oh like I want to do a gender
reveal so it's like I don't want to know
until the reveal but then you're like
you know outside of her own husband
she's like just tell me it's like that's
also like wait what like didn't you just
come to an agreement with your husband
about that does violate that too yeah
that's true there are rules that are
broken putting the friend in a situation
and and also disregarding the husband's
desire to figure out she's on across two
different boundaries and now it's like
cheesy [__] like what but can we
apply logic to a pregnant lady because
they're [__] crazy no we're not oh
we're not giving them passes no we're
not crazy was I crazy emotional yes
emotional but like crazy I mean I'm
still thinking logically but pregnant
chicks want to eat [__] oh my God I
got a [__] craving someone put
Sriracha on my [__] Cockapoo
wow okay is that true Geo did you put
the sauce on your cocoa she was really
weird she didn't have it
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo that was Christina it was like a
pickled peanut butter sandwich maybe
it's a common thing but it's normal she
wasn't normal but most people want some
crazy [__]
I don't know about that but fine
point is I think obviously they're both
[__] but I think the pregnant chick
was already Crossing her own lines you
know she said they're both stupid
immature when when somebody already
crosses the lines like you gotta just
know the other person has is is more
forgiven to cross lines too that's all
I'm saying like if they're already not
following their own rules yeah it's like
how can you get mad at the other person
for breaking the rules like you were
breaking them too you know what I mean
that's like hey dude let's go out on a
diet and every [__] day I'm tempting
you to eat cake with me that's this
we'll start right so it's like okay
we're gonna do like a three month
Journey or whatever and we're like tight
okay cool I got this three days in he
goes I'm like craving something can we
just go out in this time tasting what
he's thinking about you know what I mean
it's just like tasting it already I'm
like you [__] it's only been
three days weren't you guys competing
though yeah that's what I want yeah
get you antagonized and like just be
like yo let's go get a cake or two if
he's been doing that every day and you
ended up getting the cake yeah that's
okay that's okay because your partner is
also doing that to you well yeah that
and I wouldn't blame him for it because
I know how he is you know what I mean
yeah like if I was the husband right and
it's like all right we're gonna do a
gender or feel cool we'll we'll both
find out on the same day and then I
found my wife is trying to [__]
figure it out I'm like Willy what the
[__] that's annoying yeah I'm like why
would you do that I'll be annoyed with
that right you know it's just I don't
know what his opinion is all of this
he's just like [__] I just want this to
be over with yeah
baby ain't even mine so they're just
both [__] if we gotta pick a side
though if we have to pick a side to pick
a side then I'm gonna say I'm gonna I'm
gonna side with Geo because if you have
to write about it you're kind of extra
[__] definitely I think the pregnant
lady is the [__] oh okay because she
set herself and her friends up for
failure if she knows she has no [__]
ability to like wait and she has no
patience for [__] she shouldn't even
start this gender reveal [__] idea
in the first place that's true because
you know there is the homie that's like
I got a big mouth don't [__] tell me
no secrets yeah and I can respect that
I'm like this person can't keep secrets
and they just so you don't tell them
anything so if she already knows I
[__] kept making my
my respect when people do say that when
they're like hey don't tell me because I
just don't want to know if I get asked I
don't want to have to lie just don't
tell me right she didn't know who she
was an annoying ass [__] that's an
annoying she's like I'm gonna ask my
friend ten times a day you want to
subject your friend to this [__] that
torture damn dude that's [__] up
lighthearted it's just a gender reveal
it's not a big deal
but I wanna be able to be a girl later
if I want and her friends are annoying
dude they're her friends are like how
come you couldn't be patient enough you
didn't [__] go through what I had to
go through you son of a [__] yeah
that's true
foreign
[Music]